hey hey well first of all it's nice to
finally like get up with you I've been
talking to Davey I'm like bro you guys
got this girl she's from my hometown
she's like the only person popping we
gotta talk
I'm really excited to be here so what uh
part of Phoenix are you from Seventh and
Baseline seventh oh you're from the
South Side um I like my best friend
lived on 24th Street and Baseline when I
was a kid so I spent my whole childhood
hanging out in the cul-de-sac on the
south side
what a great place and then I think like
it because like South Mountain Community
College is right there seven the
Baseline it's changed right oh my God
we're like a Target and all kinds of
[__] over there is a white man living in
the house I grew up in I was so confused
for people who don't know the south side
of Phoenix was kind of like the
African-American American side of town
yes right yes but in Mexican yes it's
like a very
you know different there's a difference
there was a Target which was like okay
cool with that right awesome and then
now there was like a Whole Foods and
[__] when I went back it was so confused
and then everybody moved to Levine they
bought houses in Levine yeah they were
like yeah we could get a house for a
hundred and ten thousand dollars in this
suburb on the south side yeah yeah so
crazy but
yeah I love it yeah so when did you make
the move to Los Angeles to pursue your
hopes and dreams I was young I was 16 I
moved on my own with my 18 year old best
friend wow so did you finish school
no I technically did so technically I
had a GED okay and I graduated do you
have a GED and a diploma yes and special
I was on the field for the
and I was on the field with my with the
classmates from the high school that I
went to before I dropped out when I was
going to online school
I've never met anybody with both yeah
it's pretty uh that's that's extra like
I got the GED and I got the diploma
because why not get both
gotta all the way what school did you go
to were you like did you walked out on
the field on not the online school
because so I went to school in ahwatuki
okay by two years that I did High School
all by two kids mountain Point yeah
where'd you go Mountain Point yeah yeah
I used to date a girl who went to
Mountain point I'm sorry she went to
evit
did you know anybody who went to evit at
the time you heard it even though East
Valley Institute of Technology like kids
oh kids would go there like for their
electives no that's where I went to
school for radio broadcasting in Mesa
it's on Main and uh Alma School okay
Mesa so yeah East Valley Children's
Theater I wasn't that I don't know what
that is that sounds amazing yeah so
what's it like being like uh you know
listen there's some great talent in
Arizona I don't want to [__] on Arizona
but you're kind of like the only like
super [__] lit person from Phoenix
right now thank you it's so crazy like I
feel
first of all I feel kind of like
isolated and like almost like I have to
prove myself because people don't know
nothing about Phoenix right and they
don't know anything about Arizona so
everyone just assumes like everybody's
white everybody's Trump supporters which
there is a lot of that there's a there
is a lot of that also Arizona went Biden
last election somehow yeah
um but you know there's also a lot of us
so yeah it's a very like wild place
because like it is where everyone goes
to retire there is a lot of old white
folks but it's also like where it goes
down everyone's strapped the [__]
cartels running [__] it's a crazy Place
yeah there's gangs there's it's a
[__] Arizona is a wild place for sure
it's just it's kind of like Florida like
Florida is a [__] up place but it's
also a place rich people go to die no
it's literally the desert version of
Florida it is the desert version of
Florida yeah for sure do you feel like
Mexican or uh La is lacking a Filibertos
style option of food oh my God 24 hours
a day that is so funny you said that
because that was like when I went to
Arizona that was like one of the first
places I wanted to go yeah I just feel
like how are we in LA and I can't get a
burrito at any time of the night I mean
like you're if you're in Arizona you can
go to Philly's at 6 30 in the morning
you can go at 3 A.M you can go out here
the taco trucks close at two like I
don't know where else you're supposed to
[__] go to get food except McDonald's
and we're in La the city that's not
supposed to sleep yeah I'm not trying to
get McDonald's either terrible 24-hour
food options in Los Angeles we can go to
Christine's mom's house Christine's
mom's house in the valley in the 818
yeah I'm like you know Philly's is not
the greatest in Mexican food but it's
there it's there it's it's Dependable
you know you can go get a California
Burrito anytime but not after the club
you might be shit-faced go to Phillies
or Robertos or Romeros or juliobertos or
any type of Berto it's a lot of
birthdays out there there is